i was watching
real time with bill maher there was one
episode he had where he was talking
about
guns
and he was saying
how how hypocritical it is
for hollywood
and hollywood types
to be so anti-gun
but every movie that comes out
is
this just gun gun play in every movie it
really made me think like huh
like
like i'm not saying get rid of guns in
movies but maybe it's time to think
about
like maybe pg-13 isn't enough so maybe
it's time that you know let's just make
like make movies for kids kids kid stuff
13 and 13 14 15. you know
they should have that
and then
start making like avengers and all these
type of movies make them rated r
because maybe we are doing some damage i
don't know
i mean i'm not a scientist so i don't
know
in in terms of like does video games
cause violence does seeing too much gun
violence and entertainment cause kids to
feel a certain way i don't know
but there are studies about it and if
there is a case if that is true then
let's actually do something about it and
i do agree the hollywood types the
hollywood left the media all that stuff
stop being hypocritical about gun
violence when you celebrate it in your
movies